was bringt dieser tank rabatt und
eigentlich war ja von der regierung als
entlastung gedacht aber kommt er auch
bei den autofahrerinnen und autofahrern
an darüber sprechen wir mit einem
vertreter der mineralölwirtschaft und
claudia kempfert die energie expertin
vom diw wir freuen uns sehr auf ihre und
eure fragen und kommentare wie immer in
die kommentare
oder wenn ihr die app nutzt an die
bekannte e mail adresse wir beginnen mit
unserem reporter lothar becker der ist
in einer tankstelle auf einer tankstelle
bei einer tankstelle in bonn lothar was
kostet denn ein liter e10 bei dir
e10 schaue ich mal eben
211 9 viel spannender aber oben drüber
die 198 für den diese das ist jetzt kein
betrag bei dem man zwingend sagen muss
dass ich hierher und tagen ordentlich
voll aber es war heute schon viel viel
mehr das was ich mir jetzt mal von
helmut scherer erklären herr scherer in
gehört die tankstelle andere auch eine
andere noch dazu ahnung heute früh haben
sie gesagt haben sie um viele angefangen
zu anfang februar bin im geschäft 5 uhr
ist sie schöpfen und da haben jetzt
diese säule hinter ihnen was stand denn
da heute morgen als nächster betrag mal
dran 194 weil betrieb spielen und dann
ging das hoch diesen preis haben wir
behaupten bis haupt 7 und dann ging es
schlagartig auf zwei euro 20 das heißt
25 cent teuerer innerhalb von 100 jahren
sie haben einen ganz eigenen begriff
wird diese ja das sind mondpreise warum
nennen sie das monster weil das ein
wahnsinns preises sehen wir jeden morgen
aufrufen also diese preissprünge und
kurz danach aus erfahrung circa nach
sechs minuten senken wir bereits wieder
um 4 cent unersetzlich die spirale
abwärts um zwanzig nach sieben senken
wir wiederum und so geht das immer
weiter das machen wir täglich mit seit
jahren und der krux an der geschichte
ist wir haben am tag dadurch auch vier
preiserhöhungen das heißt wir fangen mit
220 an wir waren kurz danach auf 216
dann waren wir auf 214 sie sehen wir
sind jetzt bei 1 98
aber jetzt kommt es da zwischen sind
vier preiserhöhungen immer von exakt
vier cent jetzt würde ich aber als laie
sagen hohe preise sie sich doch freuen
als tankstellenbetreiber dann rollt der
rubel doch richtig wenn er sich an die
arbeit nur provisionsbasis wir verkaufen
im namen und rechnung der gesellschaft
wir haben also eine geringe provision
und der preis ist uns im grunde genommen
egal nur wenn der preis hoch ist sehen
sie ja es ist keine resonanz auf der
tankstelle wir haben in den letzten
tagen über 50 prozent einbußen und wenn
die preise unten sind da läuft es und
über die menge kommen wir dann mit dem
provisions setzen zurecht das klingt
jetzt noch nicht als einer der ja am
ende immer pro liter sprit bezahlt und
immer mehr bezahlt wenn es teuer ist
nicht zwingend nach so einem ganz
normalen marktgeschehen man müsste doch
sagen ist der preis hoch verdienen sie
mehr ist niedrig verdienen sie weniger
warum wie funktioniert das ja das tun
den konzern der sich auch in die tasche
auch von den preiserhöhungen haben mir
ja nichts und auch wir haben keine
unterstützung wir werden hier halten wie
die sklaven der mineralölverband in 50
jahren haben wir keine provision
erhöhung gehabt das ist ein unding wenn
sie dem kunden heute zu sagen würde lies
mal ein cent für den betreiber dabei der
würde keine aufmucken aber alle machen
sich die taschen voll co2 steuer dies
und jenes warum ist in deutschland seit
dem ukraine kritisch und corona der
dieselpreis um 38 cent gestiegen und
überall in anderen jungen starten sind
es maximal 18 wie ist das zu erklären
das heißt sie stellen sich selber obwohl
sie seit sie haben gesagt 55 jahren
darstellen betreiber sind die frage wie
der preis eigentlich zustande kommen wir
bis heute noch nicht hinterhergekommen
das ist also ein spiel mit dem würfel
könnten sie denn sagen
bei dem oder jenem händler teurer ist
dann kaufen sie ihn eben woanders
günstiger ein nein kann ich nicht wir
haben verträge mit in unseren
gesellschaften und da müssen wir uns
raten ihr könnt also nicht fremd kaufen
das wäre auch ein risiko wir hatten dann
qualitätsschwankungen und unsere gleich
in die lieferkette wer nicht so
zuverlässig das ist gerade in der
heutigen zeit sehr wichtig dass die
frage über diese runde und wir stehen
jetzt auf ihren tanks quasi die sind ja
so imboden drin wie lief es die letzten
tage haben sie genug sprit wenn das
jetzt gemälde noch drin denn wir hatten
die letzten tage über 50 prozent
einbußen und sind überhaupt
denn so gut wie vor hier sehen wir
wussten wir nachher noch wissen wann sie
glauben dass der sport bei ihnen
billiger ist wird weil sie nicht wissen
tun sie es ja auch noch nicht aber das
sollte das erste gewesen sein hier aus
bonn vielen dank lothar und vielen dank
auch an herrn scherer und viele seiner
fragen und probleme die ihr gerade
aufgeworfen hat die gebe ich natürlich
sehr gerne weiter an den vertreter des
mineralölverband sind wir gleich in der
sendung haben dankeschön lothar und wir
hören uns später wieder und jetzt werfen
dabei erst mal einen blick auf die
spritpreis entwicklung der vergangenen
nicht nur monate sondern auch jahre
thomas consejo hat den überblick für uns
vor dem komma eine eins lange war das
normal jetzt aber gilt in deutschland
teuer teurer tanken seit monaten rasant
stiegen die preise der russische
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine ende
februar befeuerte die angst und
spekulationen dass energie knapp wird
dann leichte entspannung auch weil die
politik hilfen ankündigte doch das
preisniveau bleibt hoch super e10 im
schnitt aktuell über 2 euro ab morgen
dann der tank rabatt die bundesregierung
entlastet die autofahrer senkt die
energie steuer auf sprit benzin könnte
wenn auch nicht sofort bis zu 35 cent je
liter billiger werden diesel bis zu 17
cent im wochenschnitt während das
174 für e10 so viel wie vor dem krieg
und für diesel 1 eur 82 ob es wirklich
so kommt ist nicht sicher denn wenige
unternehmen dominieren den benzinmarkt
und die preisgestaltung so ging der
rohölpreis nach einer steigung zwar bis
april wieder runter an den zapfsäulen
merkte man davon aber nur wenig der
verdacht dass man abzocke durch die
kraftstoffkonzerne die könnten so die
befürchtung die preise nochmals anheben
so dass der tank rabatt verpufft zudem
eskaliert der ukraine krieg weiter dann
gäbe es noch heftigere wirtschaftliche
folgen und dann hieß es erst recht teuer
teurer tanken mit mehr als einer eins
vor dem komma
tja und jetzt begrüße ich in berlin
adrian willich er ist
hauptgeschäftsführer des
branchenverbandes ntx fuels und energie
richtig nicht fuels und energy sondern
fuels und energie her will ich sonst
korrigieren sie mich bitte und bevor wir
über den tank rabatt und alles was damit
zu tun haben sprechen wenn wir uns
anhören was herr scherer aus bonn der
tankstellenbetreiber gerade sagt sollten
sie sich vielleicht nicht mal dringend
zusammensetzen und all die fragen klären
die herr scherer wahrscheinlich
stellvertretend für viele
tankstellenbetreiber an die
energiekonzerne hat an die
mineralölkonzerne also auch die konzerne
die sie vertreten also wir verstehen bei
den gestiegenen tankstellen preisen das
jetzt genau hingeguckt wird und dass
natürlich viele menschen mit dem thema
gestiegene kraftstoffpreise konfrontiert
sind und
mit ausbruch des ukraine kriegs im
februar haben unsere
mitgliedsunternehmen in zusammenarbeit
mit dem bundesminister habeck und der
bundesregierung begonnen
eigeninitiativ schrittweise aus
russischem öl auszusteigen und insofern
begann da schon ein knapperes angebot
was auf eine gleichbleibende oder
gestiegene nachfrage stieß und damit
begannen schon preise zu steigen und
aktuell hat sich die situation
nochmals verschärft ursache ist jetzt
die usa dort hat mit beginn der
sommersaison also einer einer höheren
nachfrage die dann auf geringere
bestände in raffinerien und tanklager
traf eine weitere preissteigerung
eingesetzt so sind die benzinpreise in
usa war sogar weltweit gestiegen dies
ist also nicht nur ein phänomen von
deutschland sondern es betrifft die
weltweit gestiegenen benzinpreise die
wir derzeit sehen das ist natürlich ein
thema was viele autofahrerinnen und
autofahrer im moment
sehr sehr berührt was ich gut verstehen
kann er will ich sie haben zwei punkte
genannt zwei gründe ich würde gern einen
nach dem anderen darauf würde ich gerne
eingehen sie haben die usa genannt dort
ist es auch so dass die preise gestiegen
sind weil dort die sommerferien an
einigen bundesstaaten sind und eben die
nachfrage gestiegen ist sie haben es
angesprochen
das ist aber ein phänomen das es nicht
nur im jahr 2022 gibt sondern in den
jahren davor auch letztes jahr haben wir
um dieselbe zeit auch beobachtet es gab
preisanstiege die waren aber verglichen
zu diesem jahr viel viel weniger gut
hinzu kommt auch der krieg in der
ukraine
ja so dass leute auch mit mit einer
aussicht dass vielleicht auch bestimmte
produkte knapper werden könnten darauf
reagiert ein markt angebot und nachfrage
so dass wir dieses phänomen sehen und
das ist natürlich auch ein phänomen was
auch mit dem krieg zu tun hat aber mit
vielen anderen faktoren auch heute wurde
über ein öl-embargo erneut gesprochen
auch das sind alles faktoren wie viele
andere die zu solchen preissteigerungen
führen dass das ist der zweite punkt den
sie angesprochen haben nun haben wir
aber auch gelernt dass deutschland von
diesem ölembargo gar nicht so sehr
betroffen ist weil es nur um
öllieferungen geht die
hauptsächlich über
schiffe erfolgen und deutschland vor
allem öl aus der druschba pipeline
bezieht das heißt auch das könnte man
sagen muss nicht unbedingt ein grund
dafür sein dass die preise steigen herr
scherer hat gerade von mondpreisen
gesprochen und das bundeskartellamt
spricht davon dass es eine
klammheimliche zusammenarbeit unter den
ölkonzernen gibt die die preise in die
höhe treiben
also vielleicht zum thema embargo wir
haben seit beginn dieses krieges sehr
intensiv unsere unternehmen mit
bundesminister habe und der
bundesregierung zusammen gearbeitet um
einen ausstieg aus russischem öl bis
jahresende zu erreichen und so wie wir
die aktuellen beschlüsse der eu
verstehen oder die vorhaben eines öl
embargos verstehen will die
bundesregierung weiterhin an dem ziel
festhalten bis zum jahresende aus
russischem öl auszusteigen
das stützen dieses ziel aber es sind
natürlich viele viele hausaufgaben damit
verbunden das sind gewaltige
herausforderungen dann sozusagen
ersatzprodukte zu bekommen und nur ein
beispiel wir begrüßen es sehr dass die
bundesregierung auch übergreifend
zusammen mit der polnischen regierung
und vertreterinnen und vertretern von
mitgliedsfirmen jetzt nach lösungen
sucht wie insbesondere die
versorgungssituation in ostdeutschland
das haben sie angesprochen
sichergestellt werden kann insofern
haben wir da schon viel des weges getan
und es ist ja so dass wir sozusagen seit
ausbruch dieses krieges unsere branche
tagtäglich daran arbeitet vom raffinerie
facharbeiter bis zum tankwagenfahrer bis
hin zu den kolleginnen kollegen an den
tankstellen auch eine sichere
kraftstoffversorgung für deutschland
aufrecht zu erhalten das ist also eine
gewaltige aufgabe er will ich eine
allerletzte frage mit einer bitte um
eine ganz kurze antwort wenn das möglich
ist bremen hat heute angekündigt eine
zeitlich befristete sondersteuer
einzuführen um kriegsbedingte über
gewinne bei mineralkonzernen eben
abzuschöpfen und will auch einen
entsprechenden antrag in den bundesrat
einreichen haben sie angst dass da
politisch noch was auf sie zukommt also
deutschland in deutschland werden ja
gewinne bereits ziemlich hoch versteuert
wir sind ein land mit hohen steuern und
ich möchte ein punkt noch mal zu
berücksichtigen geben
gewinne die firmen machen dienen ja auch
dazu die transformation dh den
schrittweisen umbau der
energieversorgung hin zur
klimaneutralität zu finanzieren und am
ende ist es natürlich eine entscheidung
der politik ob sie firmen finanziellen
spielraum lässt auch diese
transformation zu erneuerbaren co2
neutralen wasserstoff zur e-mobilität zu
klimaneutralen produkten für die
chemische industrie zu ermöglichen also
dass es am ende eine politische
entscheidung aber unsere branche die
jetzt sehr stark im fokus steht um eine
sichere ölversorgung aufrecht zu
erhalten hat sich ja bereits auf den weg
gemacht auch lösungen
dazu zu
herzustellen und zur verfügung zu
stellen richtung klimaneutralität denn
bei aller debatte um ölversorgung
aktuell dürfen wir nicht außer acht
lassen dass wir bis 2050 in deutschland
klimaneutral werden wollen und auch auf
diesen weg brauchen wir unternehmen die
finanz stark sind und die diese
investition in neue technologien auch
stemmen adrian willich vielen dank für
dieses gesprächen nach berlin und wir
werfen einen blick eher auf den
internationalen vergleich auch das ist
schon angesprochen worden
nina niebergall mit einem überblick wo
benzin wie teuer ist
in deutschland kostet super e10 heute im
durchschnitt 2 eur 14 am günstigsten
tankt man im saarland für zwei euro 8 am
teuersten in bremen für zwei euro 20 im
europäischen vergleich gehört
deutschland zu den teuren ländern der
durchschnitt für superbenzin liegt bei 1
euro 72 am billigsten ist es in belarus
einem engen verbündeten russlands mehr
als in deutschland zahlt man nur in
griechenland dänemark finnland und
norwegen dem spitzenreiter auch weltweit
deutlich günstiger ist das benzin in den
usa mit 1 eur 27 am unteren ende der
preisskala sind die ölreichen länder
iran mit 5 cent und venezuela mit zwei
set
venezuela 2 cent claudia kämpfer des uns
zugeschaltet energieexpertin beim
deutschen institut für
wirtschaftsforschung diw
frau kaempfert ich werfe einen ganz
kurzen blick in unseren chat hier denn
die sendung lebt er auch davon dass wir
viele userinnen und user haben die
kommentieren und auch fragen stellen und
ich sehe hier wird auch viel kommentiert
und viel gefragt und der tenor ist aber
wenn man das so zusammenfassen kann
eindeutig kontra
mineralölkonzerne die schuld wird da
sehr schnell
bei den konzernen gesucht und gefunden
und es wird mehr staatliche regulierung
für den tankstellenmarkt gefordert zum
beispiel daniel matschinsky tut das und
auch der tank rabatt ist sehr sehr in
der kritik fantastischer schreibt hier
die konzerne shell bp und andere
konsorten kommen vor lachen nicht mehr
aus dem keller frau kämpft sie sind eine
gegnerin des tank rabatt auch was sind
ihre gründe dafür ja ein tank rabatt ist
ökonomisch und ökologisch unsinnig ist
enorm mit teuer es ist verschwendete
steuergeld ist sozial ungerecht viel
effektiver wäre es man würde
zielgerichtet wirkliche betroffenen
helfen oder eben auch zielgerichtet über
die erhöhung der einnahmen dann wirklich
möglichkeiten geschaffen betroffenen
haushalten oder personen unternehmens zu
helfen das ist das eine das andere ist
ja dass man mit einem tank rabatt ja
eher dem verbrauch wieder ankurbelt und
damit zu knappheiten das zu knappheiten
führen kann und damit man mehr wieder
mehr importe braucht mehr fossile
energie verbraucht und viel besser wäre
es doch mal nutzte das geld um
umzusteigen wegzukommen von dem benzin
und diesel hinzu mehr einer
verkehrswende und das fehlt mir da dran
insofern ist es tatsächlich so dass ein
tank rabatte unsinnig ist oder falsch
glauben sie denn dass er überhaupt beim
verbraucher weil den verbraucherinnen
ankommt also einen usernamen hoops
schreibt zum beispiel noch zwei wochen
ist der spritpreis wieder beim heutigen
und nach den drei monaten überraschender
weise dann wieder überraschender weise
bei 260 270 was glauben sie denn wird er
an kommen zum einen und also entlastung
bringen und zum anderen was passiert
denn wenn die drei monate vorbei sind
ja teilweise dergestalt dass er kommen
wird denn das erwartet man jetzt auch in
die haushalte alle tankkunden erwarten
dass das ist jetzt runter geht
gesetzlich einfordern kann man das nicht
man sieht ja schon dass die marge jetzt
wieder munter nach oben gehen eben haben
wir schon mondpreise gehört also man
schraubt erst mal den preis nach oben um
ihn dann nach unten zu treiben
üblicherweise findet das so startete die
marge in der mineralölkonzerne neben in
der tat sehr stark zu das sehen wir auch
in den daten und die anteilseigner
werden da übrig entschädigt also dass da
geht in die völlig falsche richtung
insofern ist es auch richtig dass man
über eine sogenannte über gewinn steuer
debattiert oder über umsatzsteuer das
war werden eben moment sehr hohe gewinne
eingefahren und das sollte man
unterbinden bzw das geld sinnvoller
einsetzen was passiert nach drei monaten
dann ist zu erwarten dass dann der
preissprung der wieder deutlich nach
oben geht oder die politik sagt wir
subventionieren jetzt auf dauer die
benzinpreise dass es natürlich auch
keine lösung dass es enorm teuer also
das sieht nicht so aus als würde uns
frau kemfert noch hören
zumindest
würde ich sagen damit können wir leider
das gespräch nicht weiter druck
kaempfert haben wir verloren oder ist
sie wieder da nein ich habe das gefühl
das wird nichts mehr so weit also
claudia kempfert leider gab es offenbar
ein problem mit der leitung aber dann
nutzen wir die gelegenheit und nochmal
zu lothar becker zurückzugehen der
jetzt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen zeit
braucht um an der tankstelle in bonn dem
kameramann zu sagen wir sind wieder auf
sendung da ist lothar ich nehme an auch
erschweren dass scherer ist noch an
deiner seite und hat auch alles gehört
was er will ich gesagt hat wie es denn
wie es denn die einschätzung erschwere
[Musik]
ich reiche das mal soweit dies in ihrer
einschätzung was sie jetzt gerade gehört
haben vom branchenverband aus dem
bereich der wirtschaft die als sie
zugehört haben ja also von dem
branchenverband von der wirtschaft bin
ich sehr enttäuscht wenn ich jetzt einen
aufsatz zu beurteilen weil wirklich für
den will ich sagen thema verfehlt setzen
sechs die frage lautet warum erhöhen wir
jeden morgen um 25 26 cent einen
mondpreis und warum ändern wir vier mal
am tag die preise immer exakt und 14
erhöhen wir gehen darüber noch schon
wieder runter diese frage ändert sich
viermal am tag der rohölpreis und dann
spricht der wenig immer von der zukunft
wir haben noch kein öl embargo es ist
alles noch da es läuft aus allen rohren
ja und es wird wieder von energie und
alternativ auch bei der verkämpfen ich
habe einen freund der hatte ein
abbruchunternehmen und die frau soll dem
entlasten fahrrad die häuser abreißen
und wegfahren wissen sie was tiefere
schule haben die lkws gibt es schon
einen batteriebetriebenen bagger oder
wie soll der arbeiten das heißt sie
sehen diesen rabatt auch dann an der
falschen stelle also dass man ihnen den
unternehmen also den mund ölkonzernen
gibt und wie würden sie es besser finden
ja aber man kommt beim endverbraucher
der normale bürger der zur arbeit fährt
oder ist das ein verbrecher wenn der
sonntags war spazieren fährt unsere
ganze branche wird kaputt gemacht bringt
kein mensch vor danach glauben sie denn
dass dieser rabatt dann irgendwann
tatsächlich bei den verbrauchern ankommt
der wirt angekommen verzögert aber auf
der in vollem maß sachen kommt in den
drei monaten das bezweifle ich stark wir
hören doch selber schon von der
regierung wir haben keine handhabe das
einzufordern die haben nicht schwer im
wald es wird die steuer reduziert und
irgendeiner steckt sich das in der
tasche aber nicht da wo es ankommt
verstehe ich nicht wenn sie es nicht
verstehen ist die frage wer soll es eben
sonst verstehen was können wir heute
sicher sagen was den morgigen tag angeht
wird da auf dieser anzeige da hinter uns
der preis um 17 30 cent wie auch immer
fallen wir haben von keinem konzern
etwas vorliegen ich habe zwei
verschiedene lieferanten in den beiden
betrieben und wir wirst du überhaupt
nicht also wenn sie mich schon vom
bauchgefühl gefahren da werden wir
morgen 34 cent günstiger sein wie heute
und das ist alles aber in den letzten
tagen ich hab mir das mal angeschaut
wenn man diese mondpreise diese genannte
hab ja
ich würde ja ich würde gerne das
bauchgefühl von herrn scherer noch ein
bisschen weiter in die zukunft ausdehnen
und eine frage von den zuschauer mit
reinnehmen malik moore fragt macht oder
sagt
genau malimo versagt macht euch schon
mal gefasst dass in den nächsten drei
monaten der spritpreis noch mal richtig
stark steigen wird wenn viele menschen
mit der bahn fahren muss das geld her
anders reingeholt werden lassen wir den
letzten kommentar mal weg aber was sagt
denn der bauch von herrn scherer wie ist
denn der spritpreis in drei monaten wenn
der rabatt wieder weg ist
ich reiche das mal weiter was glauben
sie was ist in drei monaten wenn der
rabatt dann wieder weg ist wo ist der
preis dann wo pendelt er sich dann
werden wir wieder auf diesen preis und
sein wenn der habe ich natürlich eine
alternative findet und großzügig waren
das öl ein kaufte er sagt uns aber nicht
ob da demnächst drei steht ja das wird
immer jetzt um den heißen brei herum wir
werden das heißt niedrigere sinkende
preise erwarten sie auch ein praktisch
im moment überhaupt nicht und außerdem
muss man jetzt auch mal wenn wir nur
schon auf die konzerne drauf truppen
auch mal sagen die mineralölsteuer wird
in der arena wien fällig die haben jetzt
die ganzen tanken sind wir reden dann
ist von 55.000 liter von millionen
litern die sind hoch versteuert das
können sie mal ordentlich mit 30 cent
rathaus abgeben das geht nicht die
müssen jetzt erst die autofahrer ab
verkaufen und dann und der steuersatz in
etwa greift aber dann haben wir die drei
monate rum und alles was ja ich glaube
das ist auch eine antwort haben wir noch
eine frage die wir weiterreichen können
karriere macht er seit 55 jahren nichts
anderes als sprit verkaufen bekennt sich
auch willkommen anderen ja also das ist
zwar eine frage an herrn will ich aber
vielleicht kann dir sogar herr scherer
die kann er nicht das ist nämlich genau
die frage die herr scherer auch hatte
jörg schindler fragt erklären sie mal
wie diese täglichen schwankungen von den
zwischen 25 cent im stundentakt zustande
kommen ich kann das nicht nachvollziehen
also das ist genau die frage die herr
scherer selber gestellt hat
genau aber die können wir jetzt hier in
dieser runde nicht klären ich sehe
allerdings lothar das ist tatsächlich
auch ein bisschen krieg gibt anhand
scherer der sagt moment mal der stellt
sich hierhin als opfer und sagt ich kann
nichts machen ich bin hier in der hand
der in der mineralölkonzerne aber er
verdient doch auch mit wenn die preise
steigen kannst du das vielleicht mal
weitergeben die freiheit guter hinweis
ja das hatten wir ganz am anfang schon
mal angesprochen herr scherer eine
zuschauerfrage war dass sie doch
eigentlich davon profitieren wenn ihr
der preis oben ist dann klingelt bei
ihnen in der kasse dachte ich auch und
lerne es ist gar nicht so nein
weil wir nur eine provision wir
verkaufen den namen und rechnung des
konzerns und egal welcher preis zugrunde
gerichtet ich bin doch nur unsere
klägliche provision das heißt sie
verdienen eine gewisse summe sind wir
uns jetzt nicht die bücher offenlegen
aber pro liter pro kilometer nach und
auch der preis hoch ist pro liter oder
niedrig ist für ihre police keine rolle
nur wenn der preis hoch ist haben wir
keine umsätze schauen sie sich mal ihren
umsatz gleich null über 40 prozent
einbußen und wenn die preise unten sind
nun verkaufen wir über die menge und
dann schimmel hof wieder die einnahmen
gab es schonmal besuchende hier kunden
von ihnen die an der kasse ihren unmut
geäußert haben oder bei ihnen direkt das
hören wir von morgens bis abends werden
wir bestimmt unser ohne es ist weiter
sehr traurig wie unaufgeklärt der
endverbraucher ist er meint immer wir
würden uns das wetter spielt und die
meinung auch der kraftstoff der empfang
ist in englischer günstig einiger und
die papiere einfach nicht dass wir nur
im agentur verhältnis arbeiten ist diese
marktwirtschaft tankstelle dieses system
als unternehmer sind selbstständiger
wenn sie jetzt pächter wären noch echter
werden sie war mal ein schwarzer lang
noch nie mein gepäck stelle wäre würde
ich morgens zehn minuten der tür
abschließen und gingen nach hause warum
ja weil sie da keine luft zum atmen
haben die pächter die existieren gerade
die werden geknebelt steuerberater
vorschweben kassensystem vorgeschrieben
top-preisen vorlieferanten
vorgeschrieben sie finden die konzerne
finden auch keine premier und zwingen
die verbleibenden zu einem mehr
betreibermodell die müssen heute auf 45
tankstelle und führen und es bleibt
nichts und
irgendwie viel könnte man da sagen ist
denn pro liter sprit nachher übrig wenn
die energie steuer abgezogen ist die
mehrwertsteuer die umlagen wenn das
alles weg ist wie viel bleibt denn dann
nachher am liter übrig was verdienen die
ölkonzerne
bedenken müssten die haben uns nie in
die bücher schauen lassen das können sie
aber den herrn willi schwarz
an der front ist ja die frage
beantwortet werden auch von alternativen
um das demnächst von russland und man
versucht aber jetzt aus dem er nicht ein
den mineralölkonzern und kann keiner das
öl wird gefördert sie haben eigene
raffinerien die verkaufs weiter geht von
amerika bis deutschland das ist so
undurchsichtig
ja wenn sie ein brötchen fünf
weiterverkaufen wissen sofort und am
ende kostet ja
abschließend noch die frage was ist ihre
tendenz werden wir nach der korona delle
nach unten vor 24 monaten stand da
hinten einen euro irgendetwas für den
liter sprit jetzt sind wir bei 220
morgen früh wahrscheinlich wieder wohin
geht der preis wird es irgendwann wieder
normal also bei unserer grün
angehauchten regierung wo das auto so
verteufelt wird es wird hier nur als
finanzier für steuer lückemann uns
glaube ich gar nicht mehr an wir wollen
das auto ja verdrängen alternativ nur
wie es geht das hat uns doch keiner
verraten wir haben noch eine frage aus
mainz wenn ich es richtig verstanden
habe
ja das wäre noch so eine service frage
gewesen lothar bevor wir jetzt irgendwie
nur am schimpfen sind dass das finde ich
nämlich ein bisschen wenig konstruktiv
hinten raus was können die leute denn
machen also gut dass wird herrn scherer
jetzt nicht freuen aber aufs elektroauto
umsteigen okay ein punkt der andere ist
langsamer fahren der nächste ist wann
genau tanken wann sind die preise
besonders billig und jetzt vor allem
nach dem tank rabatt direkt morgen noch
nicht tanken haben wir gelernt aber wann
ist dann der erste zeitpunkt wo man
damit rechnen kann dass tatsächlich ein
bisschen billiger wird einfach noch
vielleicht ein paar 333 service
antworten anschluss dann noch die userin
versuchen den dreisprung
dank erste frage wenn ich richtig denken
mag gibt es den richtigen zeitpunkt die
richtige uhrzeit den richtigen wochentag
um möglichst günstig zu kaufen wir
machen das spiel an allen tagen gleich
morgens der mondpreis vier
preisänderungen jetzt abends um diese
zeit oder sagen wir mal ab 17 uhr wann
wird diese preise bis morgen 36 das ist
also für den moment in dem man kaufen
mag zu den anderen sachen kann ich
vielleicht noch was sagen zeitgleich mit
diesem tank rabatt der jetzt kommt gibt
es ja auch das deutschlandweite 9 euro
ticket das heißt möglicherweise schafft
man es die eine oder andere fahrt sich
zu sparen indem man für das 9 euro
ticket daneben die eine oder andere
fahrt vielleicht oder auch nicht alle
ganz wichtig wer sprit sparen möchte
tipp der immer funktioniert ist der
frühe und rechtzeitig losfahren
möglichst wenig im stau stehen wer
langsam fährt wer ruhig fährt kann
tatsächlich deutlich weniger kraftstoff
verbrauchen also das so im hektischen
alltag macht wenn es schnell schnell
irgendwo hingehen muss das bewusste auf
die uhrzeit gucken beim fahren wie
entwickeln sich die preise ist auch nur
eine möglichkeit die man mit dazu nehmen
kann elektroautos schwierig wenn man
geld sparen möchte denn im moment ist
das natürlich teuer sich ein neues auto
anzuschaffen weil das alte auto mit
einem teuren sprit unterwegs ist das
heißt da müsste man auch noch mal ganz
genau hinschauen was man aber machen
kann ist vielleicht die eine oder andere
fahrt anstatt mit dem relativ teuren
sprit im eigenen auto zu machen mal mit
so einem carsharing modell
auszuprobieren und einfach mal zu
schauen passt denn diese
elektromobilität und das was diese autos
heute können zu meinem alltag dass am
ende wird sicherlich niemanden reich
machen und wenn die drei monate vorbei
sind dann ist sicherlich auch die große
frage ob man da nicht doch noch höhere
preise hat als jetzt und weil ich es
vergessen habe habe ich sie schon
gefragt wann sie glauben wann
tatsächlich diese minderung wirklich
ankommt also wann kommt der rabatt am
tankrüssel am besten so richtig schöne
recht bis zu einem monat okay das heißt
und das haben auch andere
tankstellenbetreiber mir heute gesagt
morgen wird es nicht so sein dass sofort
überall der große preisnachlass ist das
wird sich muss erst der alte sprit ab
verkauft werden hatte ja vorher auch
schon mal gesagt und dann schauen wir
wie sie es in den nächsten tagen
entwickelt meine persönliche meinung ist
die ölkonzerne werden nicht der große
verlierer dieser tank rabatt aktion
werden
sagt lothar becker vielen dank nach
worten danke auch nochmal an herrn
scherer dankeschön für diese für diese
meinung ist und diese informationen
direkt von der tankstelle vor ort in
bonn dankeschön lothar becker an der
stelle noch mal kurz ein blick in den
chat für alle die die sich freuen dass
in frankreich keine gez mehr gezahlt
wird das hat erstens nichts mit dem
thema zu tun und zweitens würde das
bedeuten in deutschland keine gez mir
auch keinen heute live mehr
finde ich nicht so gut und sie und ihr
hoffentlich auch nicht an dieser stelle
der hinweis auf morgen wer sich nicht so
sehr für den tank rabatt interessiert
sondern für das neue euro ticket oder
für beides weil das einem natürlich mit
dem anderen zu tun hat dem empfehle ich
sehr gerne den stream zu diesem thema
mit verkehrsminister wissing morgen zum
neuen euro ticket und an alle anderen
vielen dank fürs mitmachen mit
kommentieren und bis bald